make your mind up time for labor
by monday a poll suggests over half the
party will have cast their vote
to determine the next leader of the
opposition tonight
sky news showed just how much was at
stake
this is the labour debate with a clear
front runner in this contest a game
changer is needed to shake things
up so some of the attacks like this one
on brexit
were pretty direct you've got the shadow
brexit secretary standing next to you is
he to blame well it was a disaster it
was an absolute disaster and i think
there is a collective
failure of leadership on brexit that we
have to own up to as a party
whose fault is labour's brexit confusion
while kierstama said we should be asking
a different question
now johnson is heading for no deal or
nearly no deal
if we become leader of the labour party
will we take him on
or we will give in to him and that's the
question we need to answer
when it comes to the post-mortem on
labour's election manifesto
two candidates had pretty clear views
you wouldn't drop
anything from the manifesto no i think
they were the right answers to the right
question so the green industrial
revolution is a key
policy it was if the electoral agreement
well i think they did it was a very
popular policy let me support becky on
some of the policies in the manifesto
because i didn't get any sense that they
were unpopular i just think by the time
we got to the point that the election
had been called
people had stopped listening but the
front-runner again had a more broad
brush answer
in that election i met many people who
said
this isn't right it's got to change
but they didn't trust us to do it trying
to maintain trust and trying not to put
a foot wrong on the subject of
anti-semitism
is hard when you're way out in front and
i'll just say this to kia
is that i believe that you are sincere
about this but if we do not acknowledge
how badly the shadow cabinet as a whole
got this wrong
we will not earn the trust of the jewish
community and those people that you talk
about
who i want to see back in the party will
never look to us again
lisa you were in a shadow cabinet when
this issue came up as well
can the person in pole position go on
the attack do you remember rebecca
lombally speaking
i think the last thing our members our
movement and our country wants
is us all trying to take lumps out of
each other but the plea didn't work as
kierstarma faced suggestions he should
be excluded
on grounds of gender i don't want boris
johnson crowing on the other side of the
dispatch box if we don't get a female
leader
this time if i succeed in this will you
work with me
to unite our party so that we can fight
as a collective force going forward to
the next general election together
yes absolutely the favorite undeterred
but the audience wanting a different
outcome lisa and andy
sam coats sky news